los restos de la guerra edificios en
ruinas destruidas por las bombas son
rosas museos monumentos y edificios
históricos y religiosos unos 130 sitios
dañados según la unesco por el conflicto
ucraniano para proteger este patrimonio
nace un nuevo proyecto digital backup y
crane una aplicación que archiva estos
sitios importantes
la forma más rápida de borrar la
identidad nacional de un pueblo es
destruyendo su patrimonio cultural
entonces cuando vimos exactamente eso
supimos que teníamos que hacer algo y
debíamos hacerlo rápido
el proyecto permita a todos los
ucranianos a convertirse en archivistas
digitales con sus teléfonos y el escaneo
3 desde la aplicación capturan edificios
monumentos y más como modelos 3d que
están automáticamente guardados en una
base de datos
debemos hacer todo lo posible para
preservar y transmitir nuestro
patrimonio a las generaciones futuras
gracias a este proyecto de la unesco
tenemos la oportunidad de crear una base
digital que las bombas enemigas no
alcanzaran
la aplicación ha registrado más de 6000
descargas pero se insta a los
colaboradores a mantenerse seguros y no
intentar escanear en áreas de conflicto
inmediato